welcome to this video playing rap from
Germany listen just I am I am Matthias
below strangely enough yes does not have
an IM bein down that some but curious if
you don't have the titles that you
usually need to pay for you for your
account does not make much sense
especially if you have the name in the
profile okay so we have a position
typically reached in the in the pan off
that's let's see with isolated twin porn
don't really know this this too well but
let's see what is going to happen
yeah black of course tries to put some
pressure on the isolated pawn and while
here night before might be a threat so i
take this tempo just to be sure that
night before it's not happening night
before to head to hit the bishop and
apologies awesome let's see yeah he lost
basically loss to move with visual
before back to his seven could have gone
down one with my extra temper for that
especially to though so nothing great
and yeah next move our next moves are
typically rocky one something like that
okay yeah that's interesting in fact
he's attacking d fall directly and in
the position with the bishop on c1 I
would have Bishop before covering the
pond and this is not available now so
hmm interesting
hmm that's a bit uncomfortable how do I
cover that I mean I cannot play move
like 92 that's ridiculous far too
passive and there's some way to
sacrifice it
hmm i don't know i don't want to play a
passive muthiya this seems entirely
wrong so I'm trying to to get him to
take with the bishop on before then like
Bishop takes Knight takes Knight takes
Queen h5 try to get an attack not sure
about that this is probably a
theoretical in theoretically explored
position but not not known to me okay
yeah this is a different way to capture
I can't check I might take on f3 was
check first I didn't think about that he
takes with the Queen I have some
additional options for example on 95
yeah let's not not clear all this
position I would love to get the bishop
here to age 694 mm yeah I don't know how
to hard to save I only have two minutes
how to tell the most precise way to play
it maybe if they have Queen g4 everybody
has got a five now maybe Queens e4 e5
they can just take yeah maybe intending
Queen 83 and trying to get something
going our probably black is fine here
but it's not easy and the problem is if
i go here h5 it's not really much
threatened
night before yeah so I don't don't
really see see a big alternative now
what now looking for controlling a form
intending look aged for up to age five
something like that is that night be
three now that I think of it have the
look hangs and the bishop Hanks this is
not very good hmm ciao
yeah probably probably this was just an
opening disaster I don't know i love the
night be three i think i almost resigned
okay not that this is bad but I didn't
really see a move after after night be
three okay what now really cook edge for
yeah and now the sacrifice that really
it really does not lead to much champ
but what else I mean it's um once I I'm
in this position I really don't see
anything else okay so this one or queen
age 5 queen age 5 just moves the rock on
it's not really but what what else
really
Bishop c4 you can just move the rook
that rotatably eight that's not really
not really much going on maybe I'm
threatening
check night h7 at least turn not not
something I'm warning nothing really
going on well I'm Quincy eight could
have flattened see it's all time this
was even a check major but okay this is
just the time disaster I could have
played Quincy ATM Chuck mating in two
moves yeah I mean this was really a
problematic position out of the opening
that's interesting i don't really know
how to react to that I don't want to I
didn't want to play passive move like
Bishop e3 it look wrong to me you can
even just take it and this i don't
really like I mean you can even go here
now okay okay maybe maybe not maybe not
because of this this type of check this
type of combination yeah maybe I should
play we should be three but I didn't
like that at all so they went for the
sacrifice and oh here i missed something
interesting i missed something here
played this one and I could have played
here and this threatening Bishop age 7
and threatening the rook so I'm winning
an exchange admittedly 444 central pawn
but that's really better
game and here I'm just struggling it's a
night b3 as possible all along here
night b3 is just flat winning I mean
this is it's too much too much very
lucky game really and this is this is
just a big smoke screen there's nothing
really threatened check nine eight seven
but he can return yeah okay I really
should have lost that game but we both
spent enormous amount of time so it was
mostly about this typical hacking in
time trouble okay thanks for watching